pues la gran mayoría de ellos van a
tener que ahorita están tratando de
procesarlos usualmente los procesos no
se estaban tomando muchos de los casos
que estaban siendo cuando estaba en la
era de trump más sin embargo ahorita
había 25.000 personas esperando en el pp
y ahora con la pandemia y todo ahora que
ya están en los eeuu las cortes van a
tener que decidir más sin embargo ha
sido el primer proceso ha sido
supuestamente muy difícil de ponerlos
con los familiares o también por ejemplo
este que las organizaciones que están de
ayuda a los migrantes realmente no
llegan se quedan en el vip y ahora pues
está esperando a ver qué es lo que va a
pasar la mayoría de ellos pues no
deberían estar en la casa es realmente
una una lástima que en esta
administración todavía se encuentren los
niños siendo encarcelados tienen que
tener por ley solamente 72 horas lo cual
no se cumple y pues esperemos que
encontremos la manera si eeuu puede
deportar miles y miles de migrantes creo
que también podría de alguna manera no
tener a los lados
en cárceles por mí por más tiempo de lo
que es necesario a joe biden prometió y
mucho del electorado quien los eeuu
incluso mi persona votamos por un cambio
de de donald trump se tiene que cumplir
hecho ninguna de las promesas más
fuertes esta migración una reforma
migratoria ahora esperemos que la pase
pero pero realmente estos niños todavía
enfrentan un infierno en lugares porque
los mismos oficiales que estuvieron
anteriormente a cargo o sea no quiere
digo digo realmente son los que los que
siguen a cargo de esta situación ahora
una de las cifras que revela la casa
blanca es que desde octubre 2020 han
sido detenidos unos 29.000 menores no
acompañados y que cientos de ellos son
menores de 12 años qué significa que
sean detenidos son diferentes a estos
14.000 de los que hablamos antes
pues o sea los que están los que están
entendiendo no son tantos están
deteniendo aproximadamente lo más grande
que había escuchado yo eran cuatro mil
por mes lo cual o sea estás hablando de
44 mil niños que tienen que ser
procesados en el sistema a la situación
pues o sea se agrava supuestamente
porque o sea es normal este número de de
flujo hasta cierto punto hay diferentes
factores que los están llevando a ellos
la violencia el final de la pandemia los
huracanes todo eso ha hecho que que
suban un poco aparte de que pues o sea
tienes una máquina parada y ahora esta
máquina vuelve a comenzar con ahora con
baile que es una de las cuestiones o sea
con las nuevas políticas realmente no ha
cambiado simplemente volvieron las cosas
como estaban pero estuvo años o sea
rezagados e empujado y así también en
méxico existen las condiciones porque en
méxico también pasaron leyes que dicen
que las personas no pueden tener a los
migrantes en centros de detención o sea
porque también son horribles los centros
en méxico o sea los niños siguen siendo
encarcelados ahora con esta ley en
méxico también los niños ahora pues de
alguna manera usted no tiene en mexico
la capacidad y muchas veces son dejados
ir hacia largo hacia la frontera por
alguna alguna razón méxico también este
pues no sé cómo es como moneda de cambio
también también le conviene hasta ahora
hace el gobierno bailén asegura que está
devolviendo a mexico a adultos solos y
familias qué pasa con ellos en su país
de origen
y lo que pasa en el lugar de origen o
sea lo que más está sacando a los niños
son dos factores en muchos de ellos los
niños que vienen osea no realmente
vienen solo vienen con un adulto muchas
veces por ejemplo me tocan los casos
porque tenemos dos albergues y los
hermanos por ejemplo a veces viene el
hermano mayor y el hermano menor y son
separados y no son familia inmediata son
dejados o sea por los niños son se
quedan también si no puedes demostrar
algún tipo de parentesco que sea fuerte
o sea también no sean o no es o sea si
los niños son muy pequeños me imagino
que ha de ser diferente pero los que yo
he visto los separan realmente los
separan porque no son océanos sus
familiares como el mamá o la papa digo
los padres especialmente y está en otra
de las cosas es la violencia la de las
maras para reclutar niños o sea de muy
muy pequeña edad para que cometan
crímenes y pues las leyes hacen que
estos niños no sean castigados de la
misma manera que el adulto y son más
fáciles objetos
para esto y tiene la pobre pandemia los
huracanes
la familia